To find the side length of each of these squares, we actually took the square
root of each of the areas. We can rewrite 4 as 2 squared. So we have the square
root of 2 squared. This square root undoes the square power, leaving us with
just two. The same thing happens for the square root of 25. We rewrite 25 as 5
squared, and then we take the square root of 5 squared, which equals 5. And the
same is true for this third case. We have the square root of 81, which gives us
9. This symbol is called a radical. And all three of these radicals are
actually square roots. It's likely that you've seen these before, but you might
not have known there's an index of two here. The index indicates the route we
are taking since we don't always have to take a square root. We'll see other
types of roots later but for now just know that all square roots have an index
of two, but it's really rare that you'll ever see written. You'll usually just
see it like this. This is a list of some perfect squares that you run into
often. You want to make sure that your comfortable recognizing these perfect
squaresm since they help us simplify radicals. Remember, this is the radical
symbol and in this case, the index is at 2 so we have a square root. We don't
list the 2 for square roots but we know it's there.